ich möchte heute darüber sprechen das
aktuell in unserem land kinder
ausgeschlossen werden weil sie nicht
geimpft sind man hat ja gedacht das
thema wäre vorüber ist es aber nicht was
ist denn eigentlich passiert die cdu lag
als stiftung verweigert nicht geimpften
neun klettern aus bonn die bildungsfahrt
nach berlin in der offiziellen
stellungnahme der stiftung heißt es wir
bedauern sehr dass die beiden
schülerinnen nicht an der studienfahrt
teilnehmen können das ist übrigens auch
geändert ich habe es nur gerade nicht
richtig gemacht wir bitten um
verständnis dass wir auf absehbare zeit
im rahmen unserer studienfahrt ein
impfnachweis voraussetzen meine meinung
ist da eindeutig die karl arnold
stiftung sollte sich schämen denn dann
ihnen ist die bonner schulklasse gestern
ohne die zwei nicht geimpften mitschüler
nach berlin abgereist die dürfen jetzt
am unterricht der parallelklassen teilen
finanziert wird die color stiftung
übrigens zum überwiegenden teil aus
öffentlichen mitteln also auch aus
meinem steuergeld und ihren lieber
zuschauer wie alle parteien an
stiftungen versucht auch die carl
anhalts stiftung im sinn ihrer partei
also der cdu meinungsbildung auf die
gesellschaft einzuwirken und heute abend
ist ja thorsten frei von der cdu bei uns
so deswegen möchte ich ihnen ganz
ehrlich einmal fragen ob das auch die
meinung der cdu ist dass kinder die
nicht geimpft sind nicht ein
bildungsfahrten teilnehmen sollten
also ich will ganz offen sagen ich kenne
diesen fall nicht es ist eine stiftung
die in nordrhein westfalen tätig ist
offensichtlich auch vom land nordrhein
westfalen finanziert wird der konkrete
fall der sagt mir ehrlicherweise nichts
ansonsten haben wir gesetzliche
regelungen die in deutschland gelten
auch wenn man bestimmte einrichtungen
besucht ob das der bundestag der
bundesrat oder andere organe sind und da
wird derzeit kein entsprechender test
nachweis verlangt und insofern ist das
schlicht die voraussetzung dafür
angesetzt ich kann also verstehen sie
sind ja auch nicht aus nrw sondern aus
dem schwarz leiter ist verstehe ich aber
wenn jetzt eine axel springer stiftung
das getan hätte dann hätte ich schon
meinem vorstand hier mal geschrieben was
das soll dass diese zwei kinder
ausgeschlossen werden das hat doch
eigentlich was mit zivilcourage zu tun
sie könnten doch jetzt eigentlich als
cdu parteimitglied sie sind ja auch im
verband mit vielen in der union können
doch der kölner stiftung des schreiben
kann ich ihn auch mit ihm als
offizielles statement von denen
vielleicht mal sich an sie wenden und
sagen also wenn sie die cdu die cdu
werte vertreten wollen dann so nicht
oder ja also ich kann mir gerne den fall
mal anschauen misst gerade eben kannte
ich ihn nicht wusste nichts davon und
mir ist ehrlich gesagt auch nichts
vergleichbares bekannt insofern muss man
sich einfach anschauen ob es irgendeine
besondere situation ist aber wir haben
hier glaube ich in der bundespolitik
auch wenn es um die novellierungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes ging auch jetzt
in der rolle der opposition
glaube ich sehr vernünftige lösungen
vorgeschlagen und auch mitgetragen und
am ende des tages geht es immer das
verhältnis zwischen gesundheitsschutz
einerseits und der freiheit dass an
einzelnen andererseits entsprechend
auszutarieren
ich kann jetzt im konkreten fall keinen
grund sehen warum zum schutz der
beteiligten da höhere anforderungen
notwendig gekostet die union denn einen
guten job gemacht in der kommunal ich
weiß gar nicht ob überhaupt irgendjemand
einen guten job gemacht in der korona
politik ich würde aber dringend
empfehlen dass wir gerade zu diesem
thema haben dir der schulausflüge das
ist ja jetzt sagen wir mal ein beispiel
jetzt was mich wundert ist dass das
jetzt immer noch der fall es war aber
standard lange zeit also obwohl wir
keine impfpflicht für die kinder haben
obwohl es für schüler keine impfpflicht
gehabt sind ist dieses schema ganz oft
durch zelebriert worden ganz viele
schüler haben im vergangenen jahr nicht
an schulausflügen teilgenommen nicht an
klassenfahrten fall frei im teilgenommen
wenn sie nicht geimpft waren obwohl es
überhaupt gar keine verpflichtung dazu
gar und weil es aber keine regelung dazu
gibt macht jede schule was sie will kann
jede klasse im prinzip machen was sie
will und die einzelnen schüler und auch
ihre eltern sind letztendlich
aufgeschmissen und können eigentlich gar
nicht agieren das kann sich ja auch
nicht jeder an die bild wenden oder
irgendwie man kann also ich würde
dringend auch die politik auffordern
hier eine eine verbindliche auch eine
ansage zu machen dass das nicht geht
dass es nicht geht dass wir schüler aus
grenzen weil sie etwas nicht mitmachen
was sie nicht mitmachen müssen na ja ja
ja auch sagen das betrifft auch wohl ein
alter vor allem die eltern das betrifft
ja auch grundschüler das betrifft also
in der pandemie haben wir das durch alle
altersklassen durch alle schulformen
überall gehabt und das ist etwas was
grundsätzlich finde ich einfach nicht
geht hier werden schüler ausgegrenzt das
ist ausgrenzung von kindern und das
sollte gerade im schulischen kontext so
wollen wir ja dagegen arbeiten gegen
ausgrenzung und nicht irgendwie dass wir
jetzt hier quasi von ihrer klasse
trainer hermann czech wie sehen sie das
also ich habe ja zwei jahre lang ist er
eingesetzt für die kinder der pandemie
auch gegen widerstand gebe ich auch zu
in meiner eigenen partei wo leute gesagt
haben da muss man einschränkungen
aufrechterhalten und ich finde es muss
wirklich schluss sein mit einschränkung
machen dass zum beispiel die sehr lange
schulschließungen die wir in deutschland
hatten im zweiten block down ich bin
jetzt gerade aus finnland zurück dort
gibt es gar keine regeln mehr jetzt gibt
es in berlin auch die testerei an den
schulen ich finde es muss einfach mal
schluss sein die kinder haben kein
gesundheitsrisiko die haben viel
ertragen müssen und das muss mal schluss
sein dass die ständig auch eine
übermäßige angst von eltern ab kriegen
weil das ist die auch geschürt wurde zum
teil aus der politik zum teil auch von
manchen in den medien aus meiner meinung
nach und kinder haben jetzt die freiheit
verdient die haben jetzt für möglichst
viel zusammenhalt untereinander verdient
die müssen jetzt ihr leben wieder
erleben können wie früher die haben in
deutschland ganz schön was abgekriegt
und das war so nicht mehr sein wenn sie
das in ihrer partei durch dann weniger
grün
und bruder fahren
wenn sie diesen fall sehen sie gehen
fürs klima auf die straße würden sie
auch für so eine ausgrenzung auf die
straße gehen
natürlich sollte niemand in unserer
gesellschaft ausgegrenzt werden und alle
irgendwie mitgenommen werden sobald es
irgendwie natürlich sicher ist und klare
klare regeln sind wichtig das brauchen
wir natürlich brauchen wir das in der
korona pandemie damit wir da durchkommen
durch diese krise die die wir hatten ja
auch immer noch besteht und wir
dementsprechend gucken müssen
und das wollen wir natürlich auch im
klima thema deswegen
klarheit die ausgrenzung auch für falsch
dass die beiden nicht mitfahren durften
weil sie nicht kämpfen ich kann mich
jetzt auch nicht möchte mich jetzt auch
nicht zu diesem einzelfall äußern wie
das wie das gelaufen ist zur korrekten
sicher sie sind generell und technisches
risiko vorlag da ich jetzt nicht
generell finden sie dass in der
aktuellen lage
schülern in der neunten klasse oder
generell schülern oder menschen
erwachsenen der zutritt zu etwas
verwehrt sein sollte weil derjenige
nicht geimpft ist
es ist immer eine gesellschaft
gesellschaftliche abwägung wie wir das
hinkriegen das ist ethisch abläuft dass
wir eine gesellschaftliche teilhabe
haben und gleichzeitig auch immer gucken
das ist das ist für alle sicher ist nur
dann können wir dann können wir
spielregeln dieser gesellschaft
festlegen so funktioniert unsere unsere
gesellschaft eine anschnallpflicht ist
ja das machen wir auch und das ist auch
eine regel da muss man sich dran halten
und dementsprechend ja müssen wir so den
den themen begegnen die in dieser
gesellschaft haben anschnallpflicht
können sie beim autofahren und wenn sie
nicht mitfahren können beim
klassenausflug dann haben sie schon eine
gesellschaftliche ausgrenzung und das
ist ja der unterschied genau da muss
natürlich immer abgewogen werden habe
ich schon gesagt das ist jetzt hielt
diesen diesem einzelfall muss man gucken
was so wie das gelaufen als psychologe
was macht das denn mit kindern erlebte
ausgrenzung sind ja psychologe wie sehr
muss man auch natürlich auf die
seelischen befindlichkeiten schauen
ausgangs auf jeden fall schlimm gerade
wenn das in der sozialen gruppe passiert
und ja
da muss man natürlich gucken dass ich
irgendwie als institution schule
gesellschaft land dann da die nötigen
vorgaben mache dass das eben minimiert
wird der bereich ist klar aber das ist
ich finde das sehr theoretisch ehrlich
gesagt weil ich wünsche mir eigentlich
gerade auch als mutter ich habe auch
vier kinder und ich habe in der pandemie
noch drei auf der schule gehabt und da
bin ich ganz bei ihnen auch die kinder
haben so viel mitgemacht die kinder
haben so viel rücksicht nehmen müssen
und zwar nicht wegen ihrer eigenen
gesundheit sondern man hat ihnen quasi
aufgetragen für die gesundheit irgendwie
der restbevölkerung verantwortlich zu
sein
und man hat sie auch unter druck gesetzt
ich erlebe dass auch dass das dass die
kinder sozusagen über die angst der
erwachsenen infiziert worden sind und
auch gefügig gemacht worden sind dass es
sich gar nicht mehr wehren und das ist
nicht mehr kindgerecht und insofern
finde ich dir hier der psychologische
schaden der angerichtet worden ist
dadurch dass wir kinder zwei jahre lang
im prinzip ihre kindheit geraubt haben
das werden wir es ihnen nächsten jahren
haben also die ak wäre das erste ja da
gab es noch keinen impfstoff da waren
die maßnahmen sicherlich richtig auch zu
sagen die schulen müssen wir geschlossen
sein weil da die übertragung dann auf
die ungeimpften älteren dabei in dem
moment wo jeder die chance hatte sich
dreimal zu impfen hätte man deutlich
lockerer sein müssen bei den kindern und
in deutschland gab es leider in
ziemlichen kultur streit der ja auch
besuch gegen ins
bundesgesundheitsministerium und
verschiedene ich komme aus bayern ich
kenne meine ministerpräsidenten der da
auch mal gerne vorn dabei war und das
tut mir sehr leid für die gesellschaft
für die kinder was man dort viel angst
verbreitet hat denn kinder sind nicht
gefährdet durch omikron ich sag das mal
ganz deutlich die zahlen haben das
gezeigt und wenn menschen jetzt die
chance hatten sich impfen zu lassen dann
kann ich doch die kinder nicht dafür
einschränken dass andere das nicht tun
und da muss man mal eine entscheidung
treffen viele länder alle länder
eigentlich in europa an diese
entscheidung getroffen die
skandinavischen wo ich gerade herkommen
haben das zwei jahre lang durchgezogen
dass die die einschränkung für kinder
minimiert haben und im zweifel mussten
dann halt mal die eltern ins home office
aber nicht andersrum